[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN MCGRATH: Howdy, everyone.
I'm Dan McGrath.
I'm the product manager
for Cloud Datastore.
And my co-presenter
today is Will.
Will is one of the software
engineers on the team.
So any time I'm wrong, he can
correct me because he actually
writes the code.
WILL HAYWORTH: Yeah, like
I go by they, not he.
DAN MCGRATH: Sorry.
WILL HAYWORTH: That's OK.
Just type of corrections.
DAN MCGRATH: Yes,
perfect, thanks, Will.
So today I'm going
to talk to you
about how you would go and write
scalable applications on top
of Cloud Datastore.
And I'll run through
some of the information.
I'll start off with a quick
overview on Cloud Datastore--
just tell you what
it is, and then
run through some of the
common architectures
we advise our customers on.
From there we'll talk a
little bit about data models.
And I'll go into some of
the internals of the system,
and how we lay things out
down in the storage layer,
and the implications
of that before we
move on to just a quick touch
on load testing and performance
testing.
But to kick it off,
I wanted to give you
some background on
the types of tasks
you spend time on traditionally
when writing applications.
Planning for the unknown
is something that's always
hard and full of guesses.
One of the things that
you'll be working on
as you approach your
launch date will
be tasks like capacity
planning and provisioning
for your application
and database software.
How big do you need
to make your VMs?
How many nodes do
you need to provision
to handle your
estimated traffic load?
How much storage do you need?
What about networking
connecting it all together?
How do you provision that?
There's a tenuous balance
you would traditionally
strike between
making sure you have
enough capacity available
to handle that expected load
and not having too
much that you're
wasting money on hardware
that you're not going to use.
There's also operational aspects
you'll be working on as well.
When you get to
your launch day, how
would you add more
capacity if you end up
being way larger than
you're expecting?
Or once you've
launched and you start
gaining traction and growing,
how do you grow capacity
in a more organic manner?
The other part of this
operational aspect
is working out how
you would roll out
updates to the application as
well as the database software
itself without having downtime.
The other thing you end up
spending a bunch of time on
is making sure that you're
using in your database
in a way that scales.
The last thing that
you want to find out
when you launch
your application is
you have a bunch of queries
that run in super linear time
compared to the data set.
Queries can quickly degenerate
from taking milliseconds
to seconds, which ends up being
a very large problem when you
need to rethink your
data base model,
and then rebuild the
database to fix it.
All of this is
essentially wasted time
that you could be spending
on actually writing
your application and
not spending time
on fixing and configuring your
applications infrastructure.
So I'm definitely
not here to tell you
I can solve all these problems.
But hopefully, I can
give you some insight
in how you could
use Cloud Datastore
and how you could
architect on top of it
to minimize most
of these problems.
So let's start off with
a quick overview of what
Cloud Datastore is.
I know some people
in this room may
have not heard about it before.
So within the Google
Cloud platform
we have a portfolio of managed
database and storage solutions.
As GCP is noSQL database
for use of facing data,
you typically see
Cloud Datastore
used for mobile and
web applications,
rather than say, traditional
corporate back end
systems, or something like
internet of things device data.
Now, there are always gray
areas where multiple database
and storage solutions will be
right for your application.
As a general rule,
though, answering
some of these questions
can be a shortcut
to understand whether Cloud
Datastore is a solution for you
or perhaps some other solution.
So the first thing you
want to ask yourself,
are you dealing with
semi-structured or structured
data?
Are you doing something that's
more transactional in nature
rather than analytical
and running reports?
And can you get away with
not doing complex joints
on your live data?
If you answered
yes to all of this,
then it's a pretty
good probability
that Cloud Datastore is
a great solution for you.
Now, Cloud Datastore is a
document oriented database
that's been used in
production by our customers
and Google itself for
over eight years now.
Its real strong point is being
a fast, fully managed solution
that will scale from zero to
millions of requests per second
without you changing any
configuration, worrying
about adding nodes, and
without any downtime
to add this extra capacity.
It literally scales from
handling your workload
on a single machine
to 10,000 of machines
without you doing anything.
What's really
beautiful about it is
under this
operational simplicity
is a really sophisticated,
synchronously replicated
database.
We currently give you two
flavors of replication
you can choose depending on
the location that you select.
Regional locations operate a
multi-zone replicated system,
whereas our multi-region
locations-- and not just
multi-zone, but
also multi-region
where we replicate
across distinct regions.
Typically we would see people
picking a regional location
when they want to
co-locate it with, say,
a compute instance
they already have
in that particular location,
or they're exceptionally
sensitive to write latencies.
If you're looking for
something that's more durable
and can survive
regional outages,
that's where we see the
majority of our customers
picking this
multi-region solution.
For you, operationally,
there's no difference.
It's simply a different
selection in a dropdown list.
Now, I wanted to give you
a quick visually example.
This is fairly simplified of
what our replication topology
looks like in one of our
multi-region locations.
So this is US
central where we run
two full replicas in Oklahoma,
two full replicas in Iowa,
and we also have what
we call a witness to act
as a tiebreaker
in South Carolina.
Now, to connect
all these together,
we run three independent
fiber optic networks
so that we can have a
network down for maintenance,
we can have another
one unexpectedly out,
like someone goes through
it with a backhoe--
unfortunately, that
does sometimes happen--
and still continue to
serve full production load
without you noticing anything.
The question was
are the two replicas
that I showed in each
region in different zones?
And the answer is
essentially yes.
The last point in
this quick overview
on Cloud Dataflow still that
I wanted to give you is--
before we dumped down into some
of the more technical aspects--
is talking about the
key integration points
within the cloud platform.
So obviously, you
can connect to it
from any of our
compute services,
whether it's App Engine
or Container Engine.
We allow you to do
exports of your data
into cloud storage buckets
and import it back in.
The same export format can be
imported into BigQuery as well.
So if you want to do a
daily dump of your data
and then run SQL statements
over it in a data warehouse
solution, you can do that.
The other one I really
wanted to point out
is the integration with Cloud
Dataflow flow or Apache beam.
This will allow you to
do fan outs of reads
and writes across the
database in parallel,
and is a really powerful
way to integrate
into the rest of the platform.
And that quick overview
out of the way,
let's go and have a look at
some common architectures
that we see our customers
using with Cloud Datastore.
To start off, I'm going to
show an example here of a more
traditional corporate system.
Here what we're seeing is
a couple of compute VMs
that connect into
Cloud Datastore,
each handling a
different system.
As an example, it could be
a sign-in system and maybe
a product catalog.
What's really good about this
for the sign-in system is it
it's typically a spiky load.
So most of the
time your database
would be sitting there at
90% idle over the week,
hardly being used except
for a couple of peak times.
In Cloud Datastore
we only charge
you for the actual usage, the
calls to the database itself,
not for having
capacity sit around.
This is really handy
because over the weekend
you're not paying for
capacity you're not using.
And when the signings start to
roll in begrudgingly on Monday
morning, we'll automatically
scale the system up
to handle that load spike, and
then go back to normal levels
during the week.
The other thing I'm just
showing down at the bottom--
which I briefly
mentioned before--
is doing a daily export
into cloud storage, which
then gets imported into
BigQuery is that people
can run daily reports over it.
And then you can use
standard SQL query
languages to
generate your reports
that the business needs.
So with the Compute
Engine example,
that was a traditional system.
Now I want to quickly
show you an example using
Container Engine, which is one
of the many configurations we
see people do in things like
mobile gaming platforms.
So what you're seeing
here is pods set up
as a series of micro services.
Between the pods and the
users is Google Cloud Lab.
[AUDIO OUT] Cloud load balancing
to distribute the traffic
between the different pods.
The first line of pods--
a play of front ends.
So a player will have an
affinity to a particular pods.
You can cache the data forum
for low latency serving.
The next line of micro
service pods behind
that you could consider
a world backend.
Now, these particular
pods have an affinity
to an area in the game world,
a particular match, or a level
that a player is playing.
So once again, you
can cache state
that is local to that
particular aspect of the game
so you can have low latency.
What you then have is
durable variety in that state
data down to data
stall, so you don't
have to worry about
the pods going down
and you can cycle new pods up
to take care of everything.
The last quick example here
of an architecture we see
is using App Engine as this
fully managed scalable web app.
You'll notice here we don't
have Google Cloud load balancer
because that's an automatic
feature of App Engine.
We're also using
App Engine modules
to have isolation between
the different micro services
so you can handle
them independently.
A little bit different here
is a module in App Engine
that we're showing writing
directly into BigQuery query
rather than using the
daily import and export.
This is essentially a dual
write model for someone
who wants to have live data
in their data warehouse.
For bigger deployments,
you will typically
see people putting Cloud
Pub/Sub in between the module
and BigQuery so
they can effectively
handle large amounts
of loads being streamed
into various BigQuery tables.
So let's go a little
bit deeper now and start
talking about how
you would Layout
your data in Cloud Datastore.
First, a quick note on
some of the basic building
blocks you have available
and some of the terminology
that we use because it's a
little bit different than you'd
normally see.
In Cloud Datastore,
you can think
of what we call an
entity as essentially
a document or a table row.
What we call a kind is sort of
like a collection or a table,
just a little bit more powerful.
Now, there's a standard
list of data types
you can use, everything
from integers to blubs.
There's also a slightly
more complex type
you can use, arrays
or embedded entities,
where embedded entities
are essentially just a map.
You can also control
data locality
using hierarchies, something
that we call entity groups.
Now, this particular
feature-- entity groups--
has implications on consistency
and write throughput
which we'll touch upon now.
Strong consistency enables you
to have multiple applications
or people see a consistent
view of a database
in a particular time.
This is really important
in distributed databases
for a variety of use cases.
As an example, if you have
a social networking site,
you don't want to have a user
delete post p, add friend f,
and then have that friend
see the post that they just
deleted about their
surprise party because
of eventual consistency.
So there's definitely
a strong requirement
for this in certain areas.
There are also other areas
where strong consistency
isn't as needed.
For example, if you're
trying to do a population
count across the US, if you're
off by a couple of births,
it doesn't really
make a difference.
What you might be
looking for then,
instead, is having an ability
to have fast and scalable writes
across a large data set.
So eventual consistency
can allow you to do that.
A quick cheat to
think about this
as we go through a bit
more of this presentation
is to remember that
indexes in Cloud Datastore
are eventually consistent,
whereas directly reading
the entity is always
strongly consistent.
The one difference
here is if you
use something called ancestor
queries that contain it
to a single entity
group, that also forces
it to be strongly consistent.
So how you lay out your data,
or how you query or read it,
allows you to sort of tune
and select the consistency
best of write throughput.
When we consult
with customers who
are writing very large
scale applications on Cloud
Datastore, I'll generally start
off with three main questions
to walk through to start
helping them understand
how to layout that data model.
The first one is
understanding the queries
that you want to run
across your data.
Cloud Datastore
forces you to use
queries that will scale by
the size of your results set,
not by the size
of your data set.
So what that means is
if you have a query that
returns 10 entities, it will
take the same time to execute,
whether you have 100
entities in your database
or 100 million entities
in your database.
That does mean we disallow
certain types of queries
to make sure that you're
only using queries at scale.
The second question we
ask them is understanding
when your traffic increase, how
does your right profile change?
So we have some guideline
limits within the system.
We have people sort of consider
when they're building it,
which helps understand
whether you build things
into entity groups or
spread it out wider and use
eventual consistency.
The first one is if you're
updating individual entities,
you want to try to keep it
to updating that entity only
once per second.
So an example of where
you might think about that
is if you're trying
to do a counter.
Doing a counter for every
person signing into your system
when you have 100
million concurrent users
is generally not a good
idea in any database.
There are things
you can consider
like sharded counters
that will split
those updates across
a variety of entities
so you can effectively
increase your write throughput.
The second limit is around
the entity group itself.
That also has a one transaction
per second write guideline
that we have.
Now, I said
transaction, not write,
because you can have multiple
entities within a transaction.
You can batch hundreds
of entities together,
and that gets considered
as one write transaction.
So you can do hundreds
of entities per seconds
into that group, but you have
to make sure you batch it
appropriately.
The next one, in terms
of guideline limits
when looking at how your
write scale with your traffic,
is any place you might have
monotonically increasing
or decreasing keys.
The way our system splits
or shards out data,
and then splits the
servers that handle it,
means that we can
sustain about 500 writes
per second on sequential data.
We'll see in a second how
we lay out indexes on disk,
but the essential
implication of this
is the same thing applies
for sequential data.
So if you're trying to index
a particular property that
is a time stamp now,
you want to keep
your writes per second
on that particular kind
under 500 per second.
Now, when you keep
that in mind, it
is worth noting you
can do a million write
per second or more across
the entire database
as long as you have your
data set up appropriately.
It's also good to note here
a general rule if you've ever
talked to a team that works
on Cloud Datastores, what
they like to call the 555 rule.
This is when you're
ramping up traffic
for the first time with writes.
You want to look at starting
at a base write rate of 500
writes per second, increasing
it by 50% every five minutes.
So using that type
of ramp up model
you can get to
about 700,000 writes
for second in under 90 minutes.
And it's just important to have
that constant ramp up profile
to make sure that we split
the system and scale up
appropriately.
The last question that we ask
is about consistency guarantees
that you need.
Just remembering that look
ups and ancestor queries
are strongly
consistent, and other
queries that use indexes
are eventually consistent.
So I'm going to dive into the
weeds for just a second here,
just to give you an example of
where understanding what type
of query you're doing can change
how you lay out your data.
So just for a
second, let's suppose
you have an employee
system that wants
to store the start and end
times of someone's shift
over the week.
The first way you might
think about doing this
is storing two
arrays of start times
in the appropriate and times.
Noting from the previous
slide, the types of queries
we support are multiple quality
filters, multiple quality
filters with one
inequality filter,
but we don't support
too inequality filters
on different properties.
So if you think that we have
one array of start times, one
array of end times, you'd have
to do two inequality filters
on different properties,
which doesn't actually
scale for very large loads.
You could change how you do
your data, though, and instead
of storing start
time and end times,
break the day up into
30 minute periods,
and then store each
30 minute block
that that person is on shift.
Now, if you account for the
day of the week in that,
that changes you're
two inequality
filters to a single
equality filter, which
is a very scalable model.
So just below the
data model here
is just a small
snippet of JavaScript
that shows you how you'd convert
the time into 30 minute blocks.
And then the query
itself is very simple.
You just use the
Query Builder in Java,
set the kind to employees, and
then filter by that 30 minute
block that you're
looking for, and you
can find everyone whose
on shift right now
and invite them to
the pizza party.
Another example
is what if you're
writing a game review site?
How would you lay out your
data to do reviews on games?
So obviously, here
you would start off
with a table or a
kind called games,
and you give it
a bunch of data--
some auto ID as the primary key.
You'd have a string for the
game name and description.
You might have a link to an
image within GCS for the title
or cover art.
How would you lay
out the reviews?
Well, one option here
that in strong consistency
is to use those entity
groups we mentioned before.
So within your review, where you
have a rating and the user who
submitted it, you would
set an ancestor key
for the game itself.
And this would force that
into the same location
on the server.
And then you can do strongly
consistent queries against it.
Generally, that would
work well, but if you're
trying to launch a
really large scale game,
and you're worried about
the number of new reviews
per second exceeding one write
per second into that entity
group for the game,
you might need
to think about using your data
model a little bit differently.
So just a quick
disclaimer on that one
write transaction
that, as I said,
it's more like a guideline.
So you can definitely
burst above that
to like 30 writes per second
for short periods of time.
Eventually, if you keep
a high right right,
though, you'll exhaust our
internal cues in the system.
At that point, we'll
start rejecting
the new write you do with
essentially a rate limit.
But you can bust above it.
But say you're concerned
that a new game is
going to be super popular.
I don't know, maybe
you're running
around the world catching these
little critters in an AR game.
I don't know what that would be.
It sounds like a
good idea, though.
So if you're doing
that, you're probably
going to end up with more than
one game review per second
for an extended period of time.
So instead of doing
this ancestor model,
you can choose the second
model I'm showing here where
we change it up a little bit.
We actually store the game
idea as a regular property
that gets indexed.
So now I can do a query
that's eventually consistent.
But I can do as many rights
as I want because they're not
in entity groups.
That generally works really
well for game reviews,
except for one edge case,
which can be really jarring,
and that's when a user writes a
review, goes to the game list,
and doesn't see
their own review.
That's a pretty bad experience.
So what we've done
here to get around
it is a little bit of
a cheat to make it look
like it's strongly consistent.
And the ID, instead
have been an auto ID,
is actually the combination of
the game ID and the user ID.
So now when you're generating
your list of game reviews,
you do your eventually
consistent query
to get all game
reviews, and then you
do a look up on the game ID
with the current user's ID.
Because look ups are
strongly consistent,
you're always guaranteed to see
that particular user's review.
So now you have a write
rate where you can have
millions of reviews per second.
And to any regular
user, it's going
to look like it's
strongly consistent.
OK.
Now time to go a
little bit deeper.
I want to share out how this
data that we just talked about
would actually be laid out on
Datastore so you can understand
what's happening under the hood.
As you may or may not be
aware, Cloud Datastore
is built on top of
mega-store and Bigtable.
So if you want to
read more about how
that some of the underlying
infrastructure works,
we have research
papers you can go
read if you're interested
in that sort of thing.
Mega-store and Bigtable
are the two technologies
we build on top of, and we
add a bunch of functionality
on top of that.
So to start with here we
have sort of a primary table
called entities where we store
all the entities that you're
writing into the database.
That's generally structured
where the key you provide
is combined with your project
ID, the name space, the kind--
all gets combined
together as primary key.
And then in each
of the columns we
have all the data
you've written.
And BigTable is a
wide column store.
We essentially just
use it for a key value
store here with the key
and the data review entity.
Well, we also have a kind
index, so we can query by that.
Any of your secondary
indexes, any time you
index an individual property,
we also write them out
into their own column families.
And the way we do that
is we take the data out
of the property you're
indexing and make
that the key combined with
things like your project ID.
And then the data,
the value, is the key
of the entity we're looking for.
We also for built-in properties,
these secondary indexes,
we index it both ascending
and descending order.
So the thing to
keep in mind there
is any time you turn on an
index for a property, that's
two index entries,
one for ascending,
one for the descending.
So moving on to a
little more complex
feature here where we
have composite indexes.
This is essentially
where you say,
I want a query using
multiple properties
within the data model.
So you tell us to
create a composite index
of those particular properties.
As you might have guessed
from the previous one, the way
we do that is we
essentially just
combine the two property
values together, and then have
the value as the key as well.
Now, this one here you have
to tell us the sort order
because we will do it
ascending and descending
for each property, and depending
on the way you want to query it
or the sort order
that you use, we'll
need to have a different
index built for that.
And then the third one here,
with my very bad illustration
skills, you would
see in property C,
I've tried to
indicate that there's
an essentially an array there.
We have three different values
that we store in an array.
When we create an index for
an array, we explode it out,
and we create an index
entry for every array value.
This is [INAUDIBLE] you
need to keep in mind if you
try to do a composite index
on multiple properties that
are indexes because you're going
to have the cardinal property,
and it's going to explode to
two arrays of three properties
as now nine index values.
You can very quickly end
up with a large amount
of indexes we're writing.
This is important when
you're doing any query that's
eventually consistent.
So as I mentioned
before, queries
are eventually consistent.
Sorry, indexes are
eventually consistent.
And the amount of explosion
of indexes you have per entity
is going to affect how many
milliseconds it takes us
in the average case
to bring that back
to a strongly consistent state.
Now, I'm going to jump back to
that entity table I mentioned
before, and just
quickly highlight
how we split up or shard
the data to be served.
Much like BigTable,
we essentially
use horizontal row splitting
to work out which server
handles which range of data.
So we'll do a horizontal range
handled by a single server.
As the load increases on
any one of these servers
that we call tablets,
we'll essentially
split that horizontal
range in two,
and then have one server
handle the left hand
side and another server
handle the right hand side.
This goes back to what I talked
about with the sequential data,
the monotonically increasing
or decreasing keys.
So when you think about
how we split the data,
or if you're sequentially adding
data to the end of a table,
when we split, we're going
to have one server handle
all the same amount of
load, and the other server
is going to handle no load.
So that's why we don't generally
like indexing sequential data.
There is another
case here, and that's
when we're talking
about a single key.
So if you're trying to
do a lot to a single key,
it's very hard to
shard a single key.
In fact, I think
it's impossible.
Yes.
WILL HAYWORTH: Alas.
DAN MCGRATH:
Generally, that will
lead to a quite
sensible question
that people ask next, what
about low cardinality data?
I have a property that's
just true or false.
Does that mean you can't
scale by that data?
Well, under the covers we
have a nifty little trick
that we call a scatter key,
which is a two bite randomized
value that we append to
every value that we buy,
whether it's the primary
key of your entity itself
or the index data.
What that means is every
time we write data,
if it's low cardinality,
we will randomly
distributed it so that we can
adequately split on that data.
That doesn't work for
monotonically increasing
or decreasing data because
a random value at the end
is always at the end
so it doesn't help us.
And so with that
I'm going to move on
to load testing,
which is probably
an important thing, even though
we're a fully managed solution,
we'll automatically scale
up and down for you,
there are a lot of
gotchas that when you're
running at low scale
you may not realize
you've inadvertently done.
Sequential data is
one of those examples.
So when you're
doing load testing,
you're really looking for
a couple of things here.
And the key one here
is hot spotting.
So that's the
example where we're
talking about we can't
split in the correct way
to handle your data.
And we'll have a
particular row that
may be hot that has
brought down applications
before where they're
trying to do 100,000
reads from a single row.
And unfortunately, a single
server struggles to serve that.
One thing to think
about when you're
talking about load
testing is very
different from the
traditional on-prem problems
you would have.
So generally, when you're
trying to do very large load
tests with on-prem, you need
to order hardware for it,
and that can be
very hard to justify
spending enough hardware
to bring your application
to the point where it breaks.
And you can understand
where the stress
points are in that application.
When you're running in
most of the cloud models,
this can actually
be very effective
because you only pay for the
resources when you're using it.
With something like GCA, 10
minutes minimum for the VM,
and then you pay by the minute.
The moment you finish using
it, you don't need to do it.
So we've had customers
on Cloud Datastore who--
with our guidance
because they are
running at such large scales--
will sit down and,
for an hour, they
will do a 1 million requests
per second load test,
a 2 million requests
a 3 million requests
per second load test,
and then they find a fairly
point in their algorithm
where an n squared
algorithm finally hits them.
It's not just data
so you're looking
at when you're doing load and
performance testing as well.
I specifically say
performance because latency
can have really odd
effects when you're talking
about applications at scale.
And this is sort of cascading
failure that you typically
see in large
applications where when
you put a certain area
of the system under load,
that keeps up but
at higher latency.
Something that took
10 milliseconds, now
takes 100, 200 milliseconds.
And that causes the next part
of the system to back up,
which then adds load
onto the next section.
An example here would be
if you're using Pub/Sub
to batch large amounts of writes
together into an entity group.
Generally, this is going along.
And it's only writing 10
to 20 entities per second
into an entity group.
If the system
slows down in being
able to pull all these
entities out, batch them
together, and write
them into the system,
you might start seeing
the batch size increase.
So you're going from 10 to
20 entities per second being
batched together to
100, 200 entities being
written in a single batch.
And we will keep up with that.
At some point, you
will get to the area
where we have a 10
megabyte transaction limit.
So all of a sudden your
application's going along,
you don't see anything wrong.
And then, bam, you hit a 10
megabite per transaction limit,
and your writes
to Datastore stop.
Now, it's not because any
particular area wasn't keeping
up, but this
cascading effect that
ended up with larger
batches until it
got to that critical point.
So that's why, whenever you're
trying to launch something
that's large and you
haven't done it before,
is really important to stress
the system beyond what you
think the max is going to be.
And then you can find these
particular stress points,
and fix them before
your live in production
because that's definitely
a more stressful time.
So a little bit.
So with that, I'm
going to hand off
to Will who will take you
through a fun little demo.
WILL HAYWORTH: Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Dan, for that
really awesome exploration
of Datastore internals.
So don't get your hopes up.
This is actually a
really simple game.
But what's a workshop about
building scalable apps
if it doesn't actually include
some sort of scalable app,
right?
So we have a small
example for you.
It's Rock, Paper, Scissors.
You're all so excited.
So this is--
especially, I mean, I
don't know if you saw me
off to the side earlier
finishing up the last
bit of JavaScript,
which I haven't written
in a very long time.
This is more of a
concept than something
we've actually built out.
But these components you can
find in real life systems.
One of the nice things about
building on top App Engine,
building on top of
Datastore and, in fact,
on GCP in general, is that these
underlying components scale
by default. They encourage
scalable patterns
of application development.
And in particular,
as well explore
when we get to the data model
of Rock, Paper, Scissors,
it's actually very easy to do
the right thing by default.
So to start here's the
QR code, and a short URL.
Go on.
Sorry, if you want to, that is.
You'll find that a page
led to some JavaScript.
And actually explore the
architecture in a second, wow,
sound like a submarine.
And go ahead.
Tap it.
Tap.
You'll see buttons, a
space for your name.
All right.
Anybody?
Anybody winning?
Losing?
Not seeing anything?
[SIGH] This is why we
can't go to Vegas together.
Sorry.
By the way, Avalanche is the
AI, in case you're-- not,
not my name.
Dan's name for it,
which is kind of nice.
Makes it sound like
a secret agent.
All right.
So is somebody seeing results?
Please.
Anyone?
OK.
So this is actually what that
looks like under the hood,
right?
The purchases
obviously, matchmaking,
are somewhat conceptual.
But in fact, the rest
of this is quite real.
So this particular Rock
Paper Scissors app,
which we've called
Rochamboogle, is
built on top of Cloud
Endpoints, which
is a serverless API management
and enablement framework that
builds on top of App
Engine standard itself,
in addition to some
other API gateways,
but that's how
we're using it here.
In effect, it means that our
app is actually serverless.
And if you were to take
a look at the source
code for this particular
Rock, Paper, Scissors game,
you would actually
see that we're
using auto generated
client libraries, generated
by the endpoints framework
itself, which is pretty cool.
So that's server list, right?
So where's Cloud Datastore?
We hit Cloud
Datastore, obviously,
within App Engine itself.
But we actually scale up
in our data model per user
and per game.
So there's actually
no concrete limit
to how far we can scale, short
of what Dan mentioned early
with respect to the 555 rule.
I think that's right, right?
555?
Yeah.
Awesome.
As you can see, Datastore
via a managed back up process
can go easily to
cloud storage, which
would allow us to have
a beautiful dashboards
and BigQuery.
Hooray.
Maybe you've heard about it.
And-- yeah.
Let's take a look.
The data model itself is--
this is NDB code.
NDB is the premier App Engine--
ORM for Python, basically.
It was actually co-written
by Guido van Rossum
when he was on the team.
As you can see, we use up a
bunch of different properties
here.
One of the nice things
about this library
is that actually lets us--
it handles the
denormalization for us.
So Dan talked about
entity groups earlier.
If we look at the
user in particular,
this doesn't
actually-- this doesn't
have the user key on it.
But the key itself, if you
look at the app itself,
is just a string value.
Assuming that that's actually
randomly distributed,
it's really easy to
grow that, as your app
grows from one user to 100
users to a million users.
As long as each one
is a different string,
or a different ID,
that's the scalable--
that's the scalability and
the underlying mega-store
app itself.
The game itself
has the same issue
where it actually uses a
randomly assigned integer
instead.
But that's all handled for us
by Datastore under the hood.
Furthermore, it's really easy--
you know, consistency
can be kind
of a hairy area in
distributed databases, right?
One of the things that
would naturally come up
when you're trying to update
something like a statistics
property, is that if you're
trying to increment say,
wins or losses from the result
of a match, what happens if you
perform dirty reads, right?
Or dirty writes?
I want to say that's
the other term for it.
Yeah.
In fact, what happens
if we actually
increment data that has
been committed, right,
or we lose data?
So NDB actually handles this.
But in the process, it builds
on top of the underlying Cloud
Datastore transactional
framework.
Because to commit the game,
we need to update the users.
So these are three
discrete entities.
Datastore can actually handle up
to 25 entities in transaction.
Creating a transaction
like that can
be something of a bottleneck.
But it does work well.
And the semantics are
actually serializable,
which is kind of cool
for a NoSQL datastore.
So this is what it looks
like to actually use
of a veneer library.
The underlying thing
is written in Python.
This actually, sorry, veneer
is our term for our REST APIs
that you can access in
a variety of languages,
from Python to Go.
This is using that library.
As you can see,
it's really simple.
You assign a key--
the key part, should you
choose to design it yourself,
is where you need to watch for
hot spotting issues, right?
The other parts are the data
store you know and love, either
from your usage of
an object model,
or from using it on
App Engine before.
Getting the data out of
it it's just as easy.
We do a query on the kind
because that's the collection
of the underlined entities.
And we do a read from it.
This is how one does it
on top of the Dataflow
or now Apache Beam SDK.
Once we have that, we
just apply that read,
and well, as you can see, we
have different maps and a sink.
And the nice part is that
Datastore will actually
manage that sharding for us.
Again, assuming
that IDs have been
assigned in a roughly
uniform distribution,
you should be good to go.
And you don't have to care,
even when your app goes viral
overnight.
Endpoints is really
neat, by the way.
One of the advantages
of it is that should you
choose to build on top of end
points, on top of App Engine,
on top of Datastore
you don't have
to worry about
provisioning servers
ever, which is really nice
because, as we all know,
scale happens.
Again, sometimes overnight.
Finally, some kinds
of data you don't
want to store in Datastore.
For this, we have Cloud Storage.
Cloud Storage has
a CDN built-in.
That's really nice
if you're trying
to serve a lot of things
like, say, that configuration
value that need-- that you might
ordinarily store in a database,
but you could easily
overload by a hot key.
You can store it in
Datastore instead.
I'm sorry, in
Storage, excuse me.
And it's globally distributed.
And remember how we
talked about splitting?
Well, you can hammer
this thing with a key
because it's a cache
under the hood.
It's a blob storage device.
So you don't have to
worry about overloading
the underlying Bigtable tablet
the way you would in Datastore.
Anyone having fun?
I know the game
is a little lame.
But it's-- but the thing is, if
you guys are playing this right
now, and we told everybody
else in this building about it,
we actually wouldn't
have to do anything.
I mean, we might make
a couple SREs nervous.
But beyond that, the
underlying architecture
has been proven to scale.
It does millions of QPS, and we
can piggyback on that for free.
So with that--
DAN MCGRATH: I just want
to make this official.
Can you read out my outcomes?
WILL HAYWORTH: Draw.
Draw.
Lose.
DAN MCGRATH: I'm really
not good at this game.
WILL HAYWORTH: Yeah.
That Vegas thing.
DAN MCGRATH: OK.
So we already mentioned--
I just wanted to put the
link back up there again--
once again, very
simplistic demo.
But we just wanted to
give you an example.
If this here just happens to
get as popular as Pokemons Go,
we can still be on this stage
and not have to do anything.
It will-- the infrastructure
will do it itself.
If an entire region
goes down, we still
don't need to do
anything because it's
in a multi-region
replication configuration.
So if you haven't looked into
it before, go to the website,
cloud.Google.com/Datastore.
Read up.
Play with it.
We have a free tier
within Cloud Datatore
so you can do 50,000
reads per day,
20,000 writes 20,000 deletes
and a gigabyte of storage
without having to pay anything.
So it's a really
good way to just play
around and get used to it.
You can look on GitHub for
some of those client libraries
that we've mentioned before.
It's built on top of our
RESTful API, an our GRPC API.
So you just do Google Cloud
Java, Google Cloud Python.
Look for that on
GitHub, and you'll
get the appropriate language.
We do Python, Java Go,
Node.js, Ruby, C Sharp.
And I think we have
PHP now as well.
We're also on Stack Overflow.
You'll see myself, Will,
and a bunch of other people.
We'll jump on there
and answer questions.
And you can also hit us up on
Twitter with Cloud Datastore.
We occasionally have
people reach out to us
on there as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]